[Music]
[Music]
ladies the electronic flies equipment
always consists of three parts an energy
source and a device for storing the
energy and discharging suddenly into a
converter which we call a flash lamp the
object of this talk this morning is to
discuss Fleiss glance to help prepare
you for the experiment that you're going
to do on on flash lamps electrically a
flash lamp is extremely interesting
thing because it's completely nonlinear
in every possible way shape and form and
every lamp is individual it's different
than other lamps so when you get through
experimenting I hope that you will be
convinced that this type of device does
have these variations here's a typical
electronic flash lamp this is one of the
large real powerful ones it's used for
stimulating lasers it's just discharges
a capacitor a very large capacitor with
an adductor in series and the one of the
biggest uses of flash tubes is for
making laser lights if I put a high
voltage on this I can break it down you
can see the discharge in this in the
device there's about forty thousand
volts coming out of this that's the kind
of electricity that doesn't hurt you you
don't want to treat other kinds of like
oh it's like twisty the same way I did
that for effect you can try this
yourself don't jump too high when you
try it the first time now I have a small
flash tube on this display equipment
this is one of them that you'll be using
therefore equipments like it's an
laboratory so no one can the three of
you can work simultaneously and I have a
flash tube on here and I'm you'll notice
there's a sound associated with this
when the sound is on the juice is going
in and there's a very act and I'm
watching the voltage
2,000 volts 2500 volts as high as I can
go on this particular unit and of course
nothing happens because I am below the
self-starting voltage every flash lamp
has a self-starting voltage and usually
when it cannot reach this in the
laboratory without going a lot of
trouble the self-starting voltage on
that little lamp is probably over 4000
volts so it'll be off of this scale but
I can make the lamp go at my command by
putting on a stimulator if I hit an
external electrode it breaks down and if
you look closely you can see a discharge
that follows the same path as the spark
wire this is a very important aspect of
this whole concept is he able to control
the flash to occur at the time as you
wish to occur now I'll put on my little
spark coil and I will turn on the high
voltage to bring it up to 2,500 bucks
and I'll turn on the spark and of course
nothing happens because I'm down here at
to low voltage so I'll run the voltage
up with this attenuator
this controls the frequency at which it
flashes
so that's 10 that's about 2 kV that
starts very good 2 kV down here at about
3,500 volts so I get a point right there
now I want to go down to about 2,000
volts where this tube is normally
supposed to be used 2,000 volts
maybe a little bit less now I have to
put more voltage on to make it go going
up going up
thanks I still on
there we go
I've got about 2,000 volts on there now
and the spark voyage is still fairly
reliable
now this is the point about this I want
you to understand is that reliability is
is bad so sometimes it goes sometimes it
doesn't go so I'm up around 2,000 volts
and I am putting on according to this
curve about 3,000 volts somewhere in
here and I get some uncertainties let's
make if down here we get zeros up here
we get X's but we get some zeros in
between if I go to 1 kV let's see what
happens then
you're gonna have a lot of fun turning
these knobs trying to figure out what's
going on there we are
that's the uncertainty point is around
30 on here which is about 6,000 volts so
I've been here somewhere the uncertainty
value for 1 kV there is a curve a bottom
curve which didn't delineates the no-go
area no go this is a place to stay away
from there's another area which is maybe
and up here is yes go ok well if you
ever design a flash equipment you want
it to be in this area and be up here in
good and strong so it never gets down
into this point there's nothing more
discouraging than to work marginally in
with a Fleiss unit where you haven't got
enough spark so the rule here is put
plenty plenty of zip into this thing so
that it will go no the object of this
first experiment I didn't read the sheet
but is to determine that curve for one
of these tubes most of these tubes I
think we've got enough for everybody
you'll be able to select out of this
pile one of these tubes and there are
many different shapes and sizes and
dimensions and you can have the tube
that you test if you want it you have
your opportunity of testing as many of
these tubes as you want if there's a dud
leave it in the box don't take it but
only take a good one how do you tell a
good tube first of all it should be able
to start at have a minimum starting
voltage somewhere down in here around
400 volts if it it will not start a 400
volts throw it out
in other words and also if you have one
that starts with a three or four
thousand volts on it throw it out what
you want is to get a tube that'll be in
the range of which you want to use that
particular tube
the electrical characteristics of these
tubes are fascinating to me of course
the light output is the most important
thing but as electrical people we must
learn something about how they operate
electrically you'll notice in this
display that there's a very nice little
filament of electricity that tends to
follow the starting wire if I put more
energy in
this filament gets bigger
and also gives quite a bit it gives
quite a bit more light and it fills the
tube and that of course is what we want
when we use a lamp we want it to be
efficient and we want to get lots and
lots of light out of it now the
electrical characteristics of these
tubes are shown in a slide that'll come
on the screen this is a slide of time
versus the voltage across the tubes the
upper curve you notice it's marked wrong
the current rises to a peak and then
decays to zero Yosa the voltage comes
down and leaves a residual voltage on
the on the capacitor now every tube
every flash - but you take will have a
different characteristic this type some
of these have these little ripples in
them and and they're always different
and this is what is one thing that makes
this type of experimenting interesting
is because you never know for sure what
is going to come out as electrical
engineers were in such a habit of
depending on Ohm's law and the other
electrical ways which calculate circuits
that we try to do everything we can by
calculation but when you work with
Fleiss lamps you have to back off every
once in a while and go to an analog
solution of the equations it's
determined by what the tube itself does
the laws of the tube have not been
completely steadied yet so we have to do
as best we can like calculating from
examples and then rushing in the
laboratory and in a few microseconds out
comes the answer and it's usually
different than what you had but that is
the real answer for that particular tube
so this is why people that worked with
electronic flash do lots and lots of
experimenting because you have to go in
the laboratory and you have to do a lot
of these things on these nonlinear
devices by using the thing itself in
order to find out what is is going on
the second slide shows
the same data plied it on a volt-ampere
curve on the bottom is current on the
top is volts at the upper left-hand
corner it starts for the maximum voltage
you have across the tube such as 2,000
volts then when the current starts this
current rises very rapidly to thousands
of amperes and then it decays slowly as
the capacitor discharges and it comes
down to a residual voltage small voids
that's left on the capacitor now if the
tube did follow Ohm's law then you could
draw a resistance line let's go back
that slide once more there is a straight
line in that back up to that resistor
one back up that other slide there is a
resistance there you'll notice that the
that straight line is a resistance line
and everybody that works with flashes
gets into a habit very quickly of
calculating an approximate resistance
you know that the answers that you're
going to get with resistance are going
to be wrong
but they're better than nothing and so
you'll use them and one way in which to
calculate this resistance is to use the
maximum voltage you have on the
capacitor divided by the maximum current
that you get during a discharge and
you'll notice that that curve that
straight line intersects the real volt
ampere curve in several places and it
gives you a sort of an average and this
is a useful concept because if you do
know the voice you do know the
resistance the tube is defined that way
you can immediately calculate the
maximum current as long as the current
is limited entirely by the tube now the
people that stimulate lasers also put an
inductor in there
so this whole thing collapses because
the inductor is what determines the
maximum peak current that flows but the
resistance concept is still useful
because it enables you to estimate for a
capacitor discharge the time in which
the thing-thing collapses the next
characteristic I want to show you is the
one that you've already experimented
with in laboratory and you know this
from old times
is the voltage from a photocell that
tells you the number of candlepower
usually up in the millions of
candlepower as a function of time these
curves have little bumps and ripples on
them they rise to a peak value in a
certain time and it takes to discharge
to rise and then it decays exponentially
in an exponential form to zero now those
of the that work in this field define
place duration as the time between third
peak which is shown very clearly in this
slide it shows the time duration of a
flash now how can all this information
be presented into a into a form where
you can use it for designing other tubes
or for understanding some kind of a tube
this has all been all the information on
a standard tube has been has been
assembled on this sheet that I'll hand
you out at the end of the class
it shows the dimensions of flights too
and we're going to look at these curves
on the view graph in a minute and try to
explain to you what they mean so that
you'll be able to use this information
the lamp in which this experimental work
was done was a six inch length lamp but
that long of this four millimeter inside
diameter filled with xenon gas at about
20 centimeters that's about 1/5 of an
atmosphere it's excited externally and
the variables that you have are the
voltage across the tube the capacitance
you have connected across the tube and
you want to know a lot of things about
this when you want to apply it to some
particular problem so I'll go over to
the view graph and show you these curves
well these are the things that we've
picked out maybe they're the right
things maybe they're not but the first
one that we're interested in is how much
peak current do you get if you're
designing a circuit how many thousands
of amperes do you get well here's a
curve of the peak peak current this goes
up to about 3,000 amperes and it's done
for capacities that go from 1 microfarad
to 200 micro frets and voltages that go
from from 500 volts to 3,500 volts so
there's a tremendous range of things
that are covered in this experiment and
I think you realize that the data for
this was obtained by going into the
laboratory and measuring the peak light
as a function of these things in monty
oum on this log plot so that you could
get the whole data on that particular
chart now the full rated value of that
particular tube is 100 microfarads at
2000 volts and so here 2000 volts you
read 1200 amperes and if you want to
know the lamp resistance you divide 2000
by 1200 and it's equal to approximately
2 ohms 2 ohms is close enough so you say
that is a 2 ohm lamp and from then on
you can deal with it as a as a as a to
own lamp other things that are interest
is a peak light if you're doing
experimental in the laboratory you want
to know how many millions of cattle fire
coming out you can measure it and you go
from that's 1 million 10 million 100
million doesn't look that high with the
same way capacitors go from 1 microfarad
at 200 micro frets and the voltage
covers the same range this again covers
a tremendous range of light over over
this range now this standard tube at
full load rating again reads eight
million five hundred eight point five
times ten to the six candle power light
quite often we wish to test the
photoelectric cell in the laboratory or
summing device we drag out this
six-inch tube we put a capacitor of 100
microfarads across it of 2,000 volts we
flash it and out will come a half
million candle part which makes it easy
for us to do to do to our experiments
this curve is a very important one flash
duration because the first thing that
you wish to know when you do any
experiments on a subject to stop its
motion you need to know what the Fleiss
duration of the flash duration is to
long you've got a blur
so here's flash duration running from 10
microseconds up to 500 microseconds for
capacities going from 1 to 100 for the
different voltages you'll notice that
there's a tendency for it to be flat it
would be flat if this resistance were
constant but it's not constant the
resistance goes up as you go to lower
voltages and that means these curves go
up and if discharge lasts longer
in other words if you have a small
capacitor on a flash lamp like I showed
you you will have a nice little skinny
dim filament which doesn't go anywhere
near as high in light level and it lasts
less much longer time so this curve is a
very useful one now the final curve and
I think one of the most useful ones is
the one of efficiency efficiency is
given on the the axis and candle power
what if you could double the efficiency
of a Fleiss tube it would be a great
thing so how do you get the efficiency
higher than 5 I just don't know but
anyway there these are the highs as far
as we've been able to get it but you'll
notice that they come up again these are
a function of capacity and voltage and
you would think that you would be able
to design all the Fleiss units to be
efficiency of 5 well that's a good idea
we should keep working on it and try to
get those up so I think these four
curves you'll have copies these to take
home with you and you can check these in
the
lab or as you wish and you can help to
use these for designing other Fleiss
tubes all the information on designing
other Fleiss tubes is given in this book
place that you've probably heard about
and the rules are quite simple on how to
do this suppose you want to make your a
tube twice as long the physics of the
tube require that you have exactly the
same voltage per unit length so if you
have a six-inch tube with 2,000 volts on
it and you make a 12 inch tube how many
volts you need on it or a 4,000 if you
put 100 watt seconds into a 6-inch tube
how many what seconds you have to put in
the others the other requirement you
have to put the same number of what
seconds per cubic centimeter in these
two tubes so you'd have to put 200 in
the second tube and the reasons for this
are that the molecules of xenon that are
in here swimming around all they know is
that they have so many joules or what
seconds per molecule and at the the
electrical grading in here which is
causing them to ionize is exactly the
same and if you look if you could get
out one xenon molecule from this and
look at it with it high glass it would
react exactly the same in these two
tubes and it would not know whether it
was in a 6-inch tube or 12 inch tube or
a thousand inch tube so those rules are
simple and straightforward and it's all
documented in in the technique and all I
can guarantee to you when you use this
theory is that you'll get the wrong
answer because this theory does not
include the electrode effects and the
wall effects so what you do is use the
theory you can do it quick and you can
grind out and what the new tube will
probably do and do I need to tell you
you rush into the laboratory and clip it
onto one of these various machines we
have there put the telescope up and bang
out comes a number
which will tell you exactly how far off
your theory is we have used this
technique a great deal in our various
development of very large stroke
equipment and it's very useful there
like went up on top of the Prudential
building is a tube it's about that long
and it's - about that big and there's
about 5,000 watt seconds into it and
just by taking these dimensional effects
we can hook it up we can find out what
it what it will do as a optical device
we can get the flash duration we can get
the efficiency and all these other
factors that we need to know can compete
immediately come out by a preliminary
preliminary try at it now the next thing
I have to show you is is discussed as a
problem that I do not know the answer to
very well and it still it's one of the
most important things in all flash
equipment and that is the life of the
tube when most people ask me what is the
life of the flash lamp I say well it's
usually too long of course that's the
view of the man and the factories making
them he wants to grind out a lot of
production but you can make a flash lamp
that will run for years and years and
years in fact the one on the museum of
science I think has been up there about
eight or ten years it quit about five
years ago and I rushed over his glory be
the thing is finally broke but somebody
pulled the plug out of the wall and it's
still going and whenever you see the
Museum of Science that little blinker up
there it is let's see that curve of
efficiency the curve of efficiency this
is a log plot starting at the bottom
with one you don't have to go below one
flash I hope none of you will have that
experience although it's a lot of fun
one flash our lab is full of pieces then
it goes to ten I don't know most of the
tubes flash tubes are made have a life
of ten flashes and their tubes of this
type I think that's
there were a number that's the tube
they're talking about in that curve is
connected in series with a with an
inductor and that curve let's look at
the curve again we run the curve up as a
function of voltage and you notice it
goes to a thousand volts and then two
thousand volts and then it at one
there's a kind of a star that's where we
increase the xenon concentration in the
stro Valley xenon comes out there and
gives you an increase if it also two
flies around the room and it's not to a
healthier place if you're going to do is
the experiment gets on between you and
the lamp because the glass doesn't go
very fast but it it does get in your
hair and cause all kinds of trouble now
the ten how do you rate a ten lamp
flash you don't it doesn't blow up after
ten flashes what happens is that the
electrodes will melt away the two will
get dark and black and so it's
efficiency will reduce so this type of
lamp which is used for stimulating these
very powerful lasers they give us a
tremendous whack its life is only ten
places and you throw it out put in four
or five new ones on the other end of the
scale at the top end of that curve it
goes up to a thousand and ten thousand
and a hundred thousand most of the
electronic flash units that are used in
small portable equipments run around a
hundred thousand they guarantee ten
thousand but you have a hard time
counting after ten thousandth most of
will run over over ten thousand but the
ones that you want to put in beacons run
1 million and ten million and I think
the one over there on the Museum of
Science has run actually about somewhere
around 100 million and it's still going
strong of course this is done by
reducing the energy in the inlet tube
and tending to your business so this
curve is a very interesting one to to
follow and it's going to become more
important as time goes on because one of
the advantages of using electronic flash
lamp as a beacon in a lighthouse or
something is the
place is a point that it will flash for
a long long time without attention now
when I was high school I lived in a
prairie town Nebraska that had a
courthouse and went up five thousand
mile snows only 500 or 600 feet but one
of my jobs as a high school student was
up there open the window and reach out
and unscrew a 200 watt bulb when it
burned out and I can still remember how
it looked like it was way up so now that
courthouse has 410 watt second xenon
flash tubes in it and I serviced in
Boston about once every six months they
keep right on going so I'm still doing
the same job I did in 1920 when I was a
high school student I still climb up
that darn tower and open the window but
I don't have to reach out so far and if
any of you go out through the Prairie
Nebraska there will be one unique
courthouse one every 25 miles
and that's Aurora Nebraska you'll that's
the only one out there with four strobes
on it so it's quite distinctive in fact
people driving along the road comes
choice against it what are those playing
lights doing on it on that courthouse
and I'm gonna be out there next week I'm
going to take a few spare tubes and I'll
dust them off clean them off put them in
but those tubes will last a long long
time this is very important for
lighthouses for beacons you don't want
to change them often the tungsten lamp
if it's used efficiently will never run
more than a month if she was
inefficiently it'll run longer xenon
flash tubes of course will run nobody
really had enough patience to find out
how long they actually will go now I
have just a few slides at the end to
kind of wind this up but and I thought
I'd show you a few pictures a few
applications this this one next slide
will show I'm very much interested
underwater
now here the strobe is not used because
of its short speed it's not used because
of its of its any purpose but the
ability to get out of a small battery
enough light to take hundreds and
hundreds of pictures a night it's been
my pleasure to work in cameras we've had
them down
oh they had them down five miles deep
and ever they're taking pictures of the
bottom of the ocean there's an awful lot
of it to be photographed
and we're still working on this dangle
of it the next slide shows a color
picture of a balloon with a bullet going
through it case any of you haven't done
this when you should have to a balloon
there's several possibilities if the
balloon is only partly deflated and the
bullet will go in and out and it will
not tear the air will just squirt out
through this hole and you'll notice that
there's a ring wave coming out from
where the bullet went in the other thing
is to blow the balloon up very tight and
when you shoot the bullet through it it
will tear and if you put the lighter on
back you'll see a little line going
through with this tear occurs the next
slide shows a golf golfer with motor
flash you've had a chance to do some of
this in the laboratory and I hope you'll
keep this in mind because this is one of
the most interesting types of
photography there is where you put a
time sequence of a whole lot of pictures
onto a stationary film so it you've got
a time record of what goes on and I
don't need to tell you to have to move
your lights around so if you do not
light the background you use a black
background use a white subject and a lot
of contrast so far and so on
and the last slide I there's one more in
there it shows MIT from with a 80,000
watt second strobe as one of these
hanging in stro Valley this was made in
1944 with 80,000 watt seconds in two
giant tubes in a big airplane flying up
in the sky and someday I hope to build a
rate a real powerful strobe not one of
these these types so this concludes this
lecture and I hope that all of you will
have some good experiences in the
laboratory